what's the difference if you can
elaborate a little bit further between
iq and g factor just because it's a
source of confusion for people and iq is
is a score people use the word iq to
mean intelligence but iq has a more
technical meaning
for people who work in the field and i
it's an iq score score on a test that
estimates the g factor
and the g factor is what's common among
all these tests of mental ability so if
you think about it's not a venn diagram
but um i guess you could make a venn
diagram out of it but the g factor would
be really at the core
what's what's common
to everything and i what iq scores do is
they allow a rank order of people on the
score
and this is what makes people
uncomfortable this is where there's a
lot of controversy about whether iq
tests are biased toward any one group or
another
and
a lot of the the answers to these
questions are very clear but they also
have a technical aspect of it that's not
so easy to to explain well we'll talk
about the fascinating and the difficult
things about all this but uh
so by the way when you say rank order
that means you get a number and that
means one person you can now compare
like uh
you could say that this other person is
more intelligent than me
well what you can say is
iq scores are interpreted really as
percentiles
so that
uh if you have an iq of 140 and somebody
else has 70 the metric is such that you
cannot say the person with an iq of 140
is twice as smart
as a person with an iq of 70.
that would require a ratio scale with an
absolute zero now you may think you know
people with zero intelligence but in
fact there is no absolute zero on on an
iq scale it's relative to other
people so relative to other people
somebody with an iq score of 140 is in
the upper less than one percent
whereas uh somebody with an iq of 70 is
two standard deviations below the mean
that that's that's a different
percentile so it's similar to like in
chess you have an elo rating that's
designed to
rank order
people
uh so you can't say it's twice
one person if if your yield rating is
twice
another person i don't think you're
twice as good at chess
it's not stable in that way but because
it's very difficult to do these kinds of
comparisons
but uh so what can we say about the
number itself
uh is that stable
across tests and so on or no there are a
number of statistical properties of any
test they're called psychometric
properties you have validity you have
reliability
reliability there are many different
kinds of reliability they all
essentially measure stability
and iq tests are stable within an
individual there are some longitudinal
studies where
children were measured at age 11 and
again when they were 70 years old and
the two iq scores are highly correlated
with each other this comes from a
fascinating study from scotland
in the 1930s some researchers decided to
get an iq test on every single child age
11 in the whole country
and they did
and
those records
were discovered in an old storeroom at
the university of edinburgh
by a friend of mine ian deary who
found the records
digitized them
and has done a lot of research on
the people who are still alive today
from that original study including brain
imaging research by the way really it's
a fascinating group of
of people who were who were studied
not to get ahead of the story but one of
the most interesting things they found
is a very strong relationship between iq
measured at age 11
and mortality
so that
you know
in the
70 years later
they looked at the survival rates and
they could get death records from
everybody and scotland has universal
health care for everybody
and it turned out if you divide
people by their age 11 iq score into
quartiles
and then look at how many people are
alive
70 years later the
i know this is in the book they'll have
the graph in the book
but there are essentially twice as many
people alive in the highest iq quartile
than in the lowest iq quartile true in
men and women
um interesting
so it makes a big difference now why
this is the case
is not so clear
since everyone had access to health care
well there's a lot and we'll talk about
it you know
just
the sentences you used now
could be explained by
nature or nurture we don't know now
there's a lot of science that starts to
then dig in and investigate that
question
you